vous savez que principalement avant la
crise covid il y avait 20 à 30% des
pénuries du un approvisionnement de
principes actifs chez Sanofi nous avons
pris ce sujet depuis très longtemps mais
elle ne se sommes pas finalement
dépendants de la zone asiatique puisque
notre approvisionnement en principe
actif est à 95 % en Europe et aux
États-Unis donc 5% seulement dépendant
de l'Asie à ce sujet nous sommes donc
moins exposés à cette dépendance avec
seulement 15% de nos tensions et rupture
liées à un problème de principe actif
par ailleurs les tensions et ruptures
sont des causes sont dues à des causes
de multiples factorielles et donc encore
une fois je ne reviens pas et surtout
toute la liste
un point cependant nous avons été
particulièrement impactés par
l'augmentation imprévue de la demande
sur certains de nos produits et ce ne
concurrents créant un effet domino à
laquelle peut s'ajouter d'autres
événements bien évidemment industriels
imprévus sur la chaîne de fabrication
donc les difficultés industrielles
peuvent s'additionner avec aussi des
manques sur des contenants tels que le
verre l'aluminium les blisters les
sachets cartons ou des sucres de qualité
pharmaceutiques donc sur ces difficultés
d'intrants nous avons su trouver des
solutions grâce à la mobilisation des
équipes de façon exceptionnelle et
s'appuyant sur un réseau mondial très
fort